Dr wallik is an expert on nutrition and
Longevity and is the famed author of the
audio message Dead Doctors Don't Lie
which has been heard by more than 50
million people get ready to learn and to
laugh as Dr Wallock shares some
important facts that could very well
save your life and now here is Dr Joel
wallik
H um since most of you heard the tape
Dead Doctors Don't Lie I don't have to
give a lot of introduction to myself
other than to remind you the thing that
makes my view different on health I
think is that I'm a veterinarian as well
as a physician and in veterinary
medicine we don't have health insurance
for animals like we do people and if we
were to use a human healthc care uh type
of system for animals or livestock uh
it'd be sticker shock for it your
hamburger would cost you $275 a pound a
boneless skinless chicken breast would
be $450 a pound a dozen eggs would be 50
bucks just to pay for the healthcare so
we learned a long time ago in the animal
industry that we could keep the price of
animal products such as meat and dairy
and poultry and eggs down to where the
average American could afford to eat
them every day simply by eliminating
health care cost we do this in animals
with simple little nutritional formulas
and that's why we have Mouse pellets and
rat pellets and hamster pellets and
Geral pellets and guinea pig pellets and
rabbit pellets we have canned and dry
dog and cat food we have pig pellets and
sheep pellets and horse pellets and calf
pellets and dairy pellets and ferret
pellets and duck p pets and turkey
pellets and trout pellets and catfish
pellets and monkey pellets and pigeon
pellets I me every kind of animal you
can think of that's been domesticated or
used as a pet or laboratory animal we
have pellets F and the reason why we put
animal feeds or animal rations into a
pelletized Farm is so that every
mouthful is perfect even the stupidest
animal in the group gets perfect diet
they can't sort through and just eat
only the sunflower seeds or the raisins
every mouthful is perfect we do that to
standardized production and it's been a
real blessing for the agricultural
industry we were so successful that over
the last 75 years we're able to
eliminate 900 different diseases we've
doubled and tripled lifespans of animals
with these simple little nutritional
pharmas and as a veterinarian it always
was kind of interesting to me that that
we didn't use that same technology for
people we only spent a hundred billion
doll figuring all this out for Animals
over a 75 year period which is nothing
um as you will see tonight compared to
what we spend for human health on a
yearly basis so it's a pittance to
eliminate 900 different diseases and
animals well one of the things before I
became a physician I was involved with a
big research project with Marlon Perkins
from the old mutel of Omaha Wild Kingdom
show how many you remember Marlon perin
great gentleman and I was really really
honored that he would think of me as a
wildlife pathologist I was in Africa
actually doing conservation work and he
sent me a telegram invited me back to
the states in the mid 60s because he had
gotten a seven and A5 million doll Grant
from the National Institutes of Health
and this was to study pollution in the
environment and the world ecology and my
job on the project was to do autopsies
of animals a diet of natural causes in
the big zoos around the United States
because big zoos tended to be associated
with big cities and if there was any
pollution problems going on in the
cities there was bound to be an animal
in the zoo population that would be
sensitive to the pollution we could use
that animal much like the old coal
miners used to use canaries you know
they take the canary down to the mine
and if a little uh gas or methane would
would leak into the mine the canaries
were much more sensitive than the men
and would drop off the perch and die
long before the men were in danger of of
blowing up or suffocating so that was
the purpose of the study I'll make a
long story short over some years I had
done
17,500 autopsies on over 454 species of
animals and 3,000 human beings for a
comparison what I learned ladies and
gentlemen was that every animal and
every human being that dies of natural
causes dies of a nutritional deficiency
disease I'm going to repeat that because
that's a very profound observation every
animal and every human being that dies
of natural causes dies of a nutritional
deficiency disease and of course that
was poo pooed by many medical experts
back then because how could anybody die
a nutritional disease in America right
there's no evidence to support the claim
that we can prevent and cure diseases
with mamin and minerals raise your hand
if you ever heard some version of that
no evidence to support the claim you can
prevent and cure diseases with vitamins
and minerals doctors say that experts
say that professors say it bureaucrat
say that everybody says that well how
many of you ever heard of scurvy raise
your hand sure you know you can prevent
and cure scurvy with vitamin C how many
of you heard of rickets raise your hand
you know you can prevent and cure
rickets with vitamin D how many of you
heard of goer raise your hand you know
you can prevent and cure guer with iine
and copper and selenium how many of you
heard of anemia raise your hand golly G
you know you can preventing cure anemia
with iron and copper and folic acid and
bottom and b12 and what about things
like um berry berry with congestive
heart failure you know you can prevent
and cure that with thyon or vitamin B1
and what about pelra with all the
emotional stuff and schizophrenia and
diarrhea and all the skin diseases that
go along with plra you can prevent and
cure that with vitamin B3 or
Nyon and all the essential nutrients all
the essential nutrients are called
essential nutrients because if you don't
have enough you get diseases if you get
the disease you take the nutrient it
goes away so any doctor any expert any
bureaucrat any Professor anybody who
says there's no evidence to support the
claiming can prevent and cure diseases
with with vitamins and minerals is a
fool and you don't want to have a fool
for a doctor that's the last you want to
have as a fool as a doctor right well I
was really pleased to see this come
out in October of 2002 this was a World
Health Organization study they said that
a study finds life expectancy closely
mirrors dietary factors they went on to
say nearly onethird of early death and
disability stems from nutritional or
dietary causes including too little food
in the poorest countries the wrong kind
of food in the richest countries and
then this was perhaps the most profound
observation they made inadequate intake
of three key micronutrients zinc iron
and vitamin A is responsible for an
unexpectedly High burden of disease now
there's 90 essential nutrients they
didn't even look at the other
87 okay and so finally finally 40 years
later they came to the same conclusion
so I feel pretty good about
that well as I said there's all these
essential nutrients there's two reasons
why they're called essential nutrients
number one our bodies cannot manufacture
them we must consume them every day
either as food or supplements number two
if you're missing them you get some
horrible collection of diseases many of
which are life-threatening that's why
they're called essential nutrients the
ones I like to talk about are mineral
deficiencies because they make up 2third
of the essential nutrients 2third of the
essential nutrients are minerals and our
Foods cannot manufacture them our food
plants cannot manufacture minerals our
food plants are grains vegetables fruits
and nuts can in fact manufacture
vitamins and amino acids and fatty acids
we all know that but if you can find me
any plant that'll manufacture a mineral
I'll give you a million dollars tax-free
small bills in any offshore account you
want okay you'll be really very wealthy
if you can find me a plant that'll
manufacture minerals there's no such
plant nutritional minerals nutritional
minerals do not occur they do not occur
in a uniform blanket around the crust of
the earth nutritional minerals occur in
veins like chocolate and chocol ripple
ice cream nutritional minerals occur in
veins like gold and silver and the odds
of you getting all essential nutrients
and all essential minerals just by
eating well is zero in the same field
for instance on on one Farm in the same
field row number one might have three
essential minerals row number five might
have zero row number 10 might have eight
row number 15 might have 20 row number
20 might have zero row number 25 may
have zero row number 30 might have 16
and so it depends on which Row in the
field that your tomato or your corn or
your soy beans or your wheat came from
what minerals you're getting to be happy
plants only need nine minerals we need
60 and so the plants very happy and you
look at man this is a really goodlooking
carrot you know it has nine minerals but
what about the other
51 and it doesn't make sense to throw
your life away or at least part of your
longevity or your health on what may or
may not be in the food because you can't
tell by looking at the carrot as long as
it's getting its nine minerals it's
happy
okay then you start seeing things like
this this is actually from 1995
healthy crops depend on healthy soil
well everybody knows that need nine
minerals but the new report says that
nearly 40% of the world's land use for
agriculture is seriously degraded which
means it doesn't have these nutrients in
it
anymore loss of good soil of cancer this
came out in
1992 they said
that African soils over the last 100
years in 1992 had been depleted and its
um fertility by 74% Asia by 73%
Australia by 55% Europe 72% the United
States North America 85% and South
America by
76% I thought this was kind of
interesting this came out in January of
2000 and this is a little report and I
never have taken the time to get the
original because this is
self-explanatory uh um some blame the
environment USDA says better test a
factor well I think it's more serious
than that they compared a 22-year period
from 1975 to 1997 on certain nutrient
values in our food and they took the 10
most or 12 most popular vegetables that
are grown in eaten in America including
broccoli and cabbage carrots cauliflower
collards Dayan uh kale mustard greens
onions parsley turnip greens water crust
Etc they found out that there's a 53%
drop in the calcium values they found
out there's a 38% drop in vitamin A 48%
drop in ribal and B2 35% less of f or B1
and a 29% less niin or vitamin B3 and
again the reason is if you're not
putting the essential minerals in the
soil that the plant needs slowly slowly
their ability to manufacture vitamins
begins to drop we know that today
there's only about 8% protein in our
wheat 1900 there's 23% protein in our
wheat
okay this is not a mystery that you can
prevent and cure diseases with vitamins
minerals this came out in 1992 cover
article Time Magazine the real power of
vitamins new research shows it may help
fight cancer heart disease and the
ravages of
Aging now was very obvious after writing
some 75 scientific articles on on these
diseases that were caused by
deficiencies of vitamins and minerals
and trace minerals and amino acids and
fatty acids in animals and people 75
scientific articles were published in
medical journals and Veterinary journals
pathology
journals um wrote chapters for eight
multi-author textbooks on the subject
wrote a big textbook of my own big
thousand page textbook uh trying to
educate medical students was not very
successful at that and was very obvious
nothing was going to happen so I went
back to school and became a physician
and in 1978 began to use these
Veterinary nutritional Farm was my human
patients and one of the things I wanted
to do special for my patients was to get
them to live to be an average of 100
instead of 75 so I began to collect
information on what it takes to live to
be 100 instead of 75 and it very
interesting a certain percentage of my
patients back then in 1978 would say
things like I don't think I want to live
to be a hund I said well why wouldn't
you want to live to be 100 well I don't
want to wind up in a nursing home and be
abused and I I thought that was kind of
um um reasonable concern so I began to
collect information on 100y olds that
would satisfy me that I was doing the
right thing to help my patients live to
be hundred this is a sort of evidence
you could find this happens to be from
September 2000 this is a cover of this
particular issue of Scientific American
it's a great little scientific journal
that they use to teach the scientific
method to high school kids and college
students and they write it in the fifth
grade reading level so college students
can understand
it and this particular issue was almost
entirely devoted to human longevity they
had articles in there by experts in
gerentology and genetics and nutrition
and there was a little summary at the
end to tell you what you were supposed
to learn in this issue and they were
editorially scratching their head trying
to figure out what was going on because
um they were trying to find out what it
was it would take people to live the 100
and they compared the people who didn't
listen to their doctors or the people
who did listen to their doctors they
found out that the ones who did not
listen to their Doctors live longer the
ones who listen to the
doctors
huh and U something we've known for a
long a long time right so scientifically
they observed that and they found out
that the people who live longer salted
their food ate eggs every day cooked and
ate with butter um didn't use margarine
many of them smoked uh many of made
white lining behind the barn and were
drunk all the time
um the only exercise they did when they
came home after work was to fall asleep
on the floor they didn't come home take
a shower and you know go to the fitness
center and
um uh I said they ate eggs instead of at
egg beers they used butter instead of
margarine they ate their chicken
skin and they were just flabbergasted
they couldn't figure out why these
people doing all the wrong things were
living so
long living so long well obviously it's
because the people who are getting
advice from doctors are getting
inappropriate advice if the advice the
doctors were giving was correct then
there should be a lot of people living
to be 100 who follow the doctor's advice
so we're going to look at some of that
that first thing I wanted to do is get
some scientific evidence on what it
would take to live to be 100 and I I
look for an animal model being a
veterinarian and a pathologist I looked
for an animal model first and I ran into
doing some research I ran into some
stuff that was published in the 1860s
1863 one was written by um uh William
Banting on how to cure corpulence
corpulence is an old timey word for
obesity and this was back in 1863 he
talked about a low carb diet kind of
like the Atkins diet maybe it should be
the Banting diet you know instead of the
Atkins diet and then in 1935 a guy who'
been doing all his research in the 1920s
by the name of Clive McCay came out with
his Landmark article in 1935 and what he
did was essentially take three groups of
rats group number one he gave the rat
pellet of the day and these rats live to
be an average of two years which is
really super because prior of this rat
pellet coming out with all of the
nutritional knowledge of the time people
who are using rats and mice and rabbits
for research would give them rolled oats
and carrots and cabbage and things like
that they might live to be 11 months
after weaning instead of two years so it
really good to have a laboratory animal
and a food that you could give them that
routinely allowed them to live B2 he
then took the second group gave him the
same basic pellet as group number one
but he cut the carbohydrate calories by
30% kept the vitamins minerals the same
and they live to be 50% older three
years got kind of excited about that
took group number three cut the
carbohydrate calories from group number
one by 60% kept the vitamins minerals
the same they lived twice as long they
lived be four years of age and they
really got excited about cutting this
carbohydrate calories thing but it
wasn't just that and they redid the
studies with spiders and beetles and
worms and pigeons and all kinds of
animals they found out that it was the
density of the vitamins and minerals per
remaining carbohydrate calorie that was
the the basic reason because he had
always kept the vitamins and minerals
the same when he dropped the calories he
didn't didn't just drop the percentage
of food he dropped only the carbohydrate
calories keeping everything else the
same so in group number three there was
like three times more vitamins and
minerals per carbohydrate calorie than
there was in group number one now that I
had an animal model and had some idea
what to do I began to look for a human
model and I ran into a guy by the named
art link letter how many of you heard of
art link letter okay great guy he was
funny he and I put he and Jack Benny and
ren Skelton and Milton Burl all in the
same same group they could tell funny
stories without saying dirty words and
things and great family
Comedians and art linkl wanted to live
to be 100 and uh he wanted to live be
hund because he read this book it was a
Pulitzer prizewinning book published in
1933 called Lost Horizon it was written
by James Hilton and in this book Lost
Horizon James Hilton coined the term
shangra La how many you heard of shangra
La okay well that's where that came from
that book and art linkler got real
excited about living to be 100 well the
book was actually written WR about a a
people called the hanza how many of you
heard of the hanzas okay well the hanzas
come from Northeast of Pakistan and
they're third world country obviously
and and Art Linkletter hired an eye
doctor by the name of Alan banck Dr
Allen Banick and this eye doctor was
kind of an amateur farmer and and Art
Linkletter funded him to go there for
six months during the growing season and
find out what their secret was to live
to the 100 and it was very obvious from
reading the book that Alan Banick had
not read Clive mccay's material on his
wraps and he was just making lots of
observations didn't give his opinion
what was important but he was a very
good Observer and one of the things he
found out there these people were third
world country they had no electricity no
indoor plumbing no hospitals no
pharmacies no clinics no doctors they
just use home remedies like herbs and
massage therapy and that sort of thing
and um yet they were the healthiest and
longest lived people on Earth they came
from a little mountain range little
known mountain range by the name of the
kakum mountains about 800 miles east of
the himalayans often times people say
they're from the himalayans but they're
from the K kakro mountains
and um one of the things Dr banck
observed was that they would irrigate
with water that was kind of gray and
opaque it had lots of silt in it from
the glacier grinding up the mountain
rocks and they would irrigate with this
glacial Water full of this rock silt is
finally ground up Rock silt about the
same particle size as telk and it
contained over 60 minerals and they
would irrigate with this and as the
water percolated down into their fields
and their Gardens it left a/ inch to 1
inch of this gray silt on top of the
soil and before it dried they would run
out with their hes and rakes they would
ho and rake the silt down into the soil
before it blew
away now these people lived at the
19,500 Ft
level now at 19,500 FT you can't grow
corn and potatoes and
rice okay they could grow wheat and rye
and barley but because the very short
growing season their yields were very
very tiny their only carbohydrate they
ate during the day the only carbohydrate
they ate during the day was a little
tartia one tartia a day little Tara
little round flatbread that was it no
other carbohydrate the majority of their
food was goat and lamb and mutton and
and camel and and things like um uh yak
and rabbits and they'd get some wild
sheep and goats in the area they eat
chickens and and eggs they didn't have
fish in those areas they were too high
up for fish and so they and they cooked
in butter they Ed milk and cheese and
yogurt they could store um Dairy protein
as cheese and yogurt and that was it
they had a little garden they grow a
little bit of cabbage and
tomatoes nothing else they would also
take the wood ashes from their fires or
cooking and heating fires and put it in
their Gardens how many of you ever put
wood ases from a fire into your garden
yeah this is a very old European and
Asian custom and somehow somebody
learned that by putting the wood ashes
from your fires into your Gardens that
increases the yields and makes the food
taste better and so forth well it turns
out the wood ashes are the minerals that
are left when you burn away the carbon
in the wood so now I had not only an
animal model but a human model they had
a renewable source of minerals in their
food they were on a low carbohydrate
diet and it to me it seemed it explained
why they lived to be a ripe old age and
were very productive I also began to
collect birthday announcements and
obituaries of people who lived be 100 I
want to see really what happened to
people they live be 100 so I'll show you
a few Ralph Charles from Somerset Ohio
about in the middle of the state back in
October of 1999 turned 100 and they had
a nice little newspaper article about
him and told his story The fascinating
thing to me about Ralph Charles was that
at age 100 he was still piloting charter
flights and carrying paying passengers
around the central part of the United
States um he used his single engine
aranka aircraft uh he um didn't have any
restrictions on his health papers or his
license now to me he doesn't look like
what you would expect a decrepit
100-year-old to look like to me he's
very vibrant uh he looks like he's maybe
in his late 70s or early 80s and he's
100 years old and still piloting I mean
you can imagine if he had Alzheimer's
disease he'd get up there and he'd say
excuse me ma'am where are we going
that'd make you nervous wouldn't
it but he didn't have those problems
obviously for you ladies I'm going to
throw in Connie Douglas Reed leaves uh
back in September of 2002 she turned
101 when she turned 101 September 26th
2002 she was inducted into the cowgirl
Hall of Fame and her personal motto was
always saddle your own horse and uh to
me she looks like one of those feisty
little people that wouldn't listen to a
doctor you know she's got her thumbs in
her belt she's got her shoulders back
her chins out you can just imagine a
doctor saying to her look Connie you're
101 years old now it's time to give up
salt we got to worry about your blood
pressure it's time to give up eggs and
butter we got to worry about your
cholesterol and she's going to say well
up yours Doc and I've been eating salt
and butter since before you were born
and eggs before you're born I'm not
going to give that up you can just see
her she is not a shrinking
violet for those of you that are a
little more gential in May of uh 2001
this fell here Harold Stillson from
Deerfield Beach Florida turned 101 went
out and played golf for his birthday and
he hit a sixth hole in one at
101 now you have to have a strong grip
you have to be able to see 108 yards
uh you know you have to have good ey
hand coordination you have to have good
memory you can't have Al disas you can
imagine getting that Golf Club up there
and saying is this baseball I mean what
am I doing here right and so he's color
coordinated it doesn't get any better
than that for 101 years old I think he
looks pretty good for
101 and this F Antonio Todd from
Sardinia uh the island Fally island
nation
um west of the Mainland of Italy back in
January of 2001 turned 112 and he
attributed his longevity to drinking one
glass of red wine a day there's a
certain Mount ability to that because in
the red wine there are these
antioxidants that we know reduce your
risk of of heart disease and um cancer
you can get those same antioxidants and
fruits and vegetables you don't need to
drink the wine
necessarily it doesn't seem to matter
what you eat as long as you keep keep
the carbohydrates down and the vitamins
and minerals up that seems to be the
thread the Common Thread between all
100y olds I'll show you an example this
gal here dorbe from South
Africa was born in 1881 and in 1995 she
turned 14 and when she was asked Dora
what do you attribute Your Health and
Longevity to she said well I ate Locust
you know the Grasshoppers you know about
grasshoppers here right pumpkin seeds
tortoise meat wild herbs Drive fruit and
a cup of coffee you notice it doesn't
say bread you notice it doesn't say
potatoes it doesn't say rice it doesn't
say
corn the only carbohydrate might be a
little bit of that dried fruit she got
her protein from the Locust from The
Grasshoppers and the Tortoise meat she
got her essential fatty acids from the
pumpkin seeds and if she ate the herbs
grain she got a little bit of vitamin C
and folic acid and beta
carotene and she lived to be 114 she
probably lived longer than that I didn't
keep track of her after that birthday
announcement
yeah crickets won't work okay February
15 2003 this gal here Maddie Owens 119
died at age 119 and she grew up in South
Carolina and apparently um when she was
born in
1883 uh she was still working in the
cotton fields Owens told her family of
her hard work in the cotton fields I
guarantee
you that um she didn't have vaccinations
I guarantee you that she didn't have
antibiotics I guarantee you she didn't
have three good Square meals a day but
I'll bet you because I spent a lot of
time in Africa two years in Africa and I
know what they did with their wood ashes
from their cooking fires they always put
it in their Gardens even in Africa for
their cabbage and their um tomatoes and
beans and so forth and so I bet that her
parents put the wood ashes from the
cooking fires into the gardens and one
of my my favorite birthday announcements
goes back to
1995 uh this was a birthday announcement
for Jean kman from France and she was
documented by the Guinness rer Records
being the oldest living woman at the
time there was more than 200 women who
claimed to be older than she they didn't
have the paperwork to prove it Jee Kel
had the paperwork to prove to the
satisfaction of the Guinness World Book
of Records that February 21st 1995 she
was in fact 120 February 21st 1996 she
turned 121 February 21st 1997 she turned
22 and she died in August of 1997 at age
of 122 years in 164 days she died
suddenly of a stroke she was up cooking
her eggs and singing
fahaka faraka
faraka fell over dead didn't have
Alzheimer disease she was bright
mentally alert until the moment she died
she didn't have cardiovas disease she
didn't have diabetes she didn't have
cancer and um she did have rheumatoid
arthritis in her hands you can see but
that's pretty good live be 122 and A2 d
suddenly without being mentally
infirm I mean that's the way to do it
right I thought this was was kind of
cute I was in Adelaide Australia back in
October of 2003 when this came out in an
Australian newspaper world's oldest man
dies at 122 A Cambodian TIG tiger Hunter
by the name of sege who is also the
martial arts expert attributed his
longevity and that of his wife I'm
assuming a widow now long o 108 to
smoking in
prayer that's kind of a strange
combination but I'm sure he had got some
mineral
somewhere again this is an Australian
newspaper came out in March of 2003 a
Brazilian be believed to be the world's
oldest woman died at the age of 124
Maria ET Lina dos Santos died of a
stroke her birth certificate says she
was the descendant of African slaves
born in July of
1878 you think she got vaccinations and
antibiotics you think she had three good
Square meals a day no she was born in a
straw Hut cocked with cow
dung and probably led a pretty miserable
life as she was growing up but I
guarantee you they put their wood
ashes from their cooking fires into the
gardens they didn't have doctors and
they didn't have Hospitals and Clinics
and they didn't have
Pharmaceuticals and know she lived be
124 I'll give you two more than I think
you'll get the idea and then we'll move
on but I think these are interesting
they all tell
stories this next one I identified with
because I grew up in a little cattle
farm in Missouri we raised um um
purebred Angus Cattle we also had a
little Feeder operation to keep a kind
of an even cash flow and so I identified
with this guy he was a cattle farmer
from a little town outside of Catman
dyal in the land mountains and according
to his obituary he never saw a doctor
never set foot in a hospital he smoked
two packs of cigarettes a day for 120
years he wasn't a vegetarian raising
cattle he ate red meat every day and um
in April of 1998 he died age
141 when he was a young man he led the
first land survey team around Catman de
in
1888 the last one I want to share with
you tells a lot of stories it's one of
my favorite obituaries it's about an
Iranian Woman by the name of Mizumi dusy
and um this was published in the Rocky
Mountain news wire service out of Denver
Colorado in January of 1995 it said mumi
Dy died at age of 161 this seems pretty
outrageous but you have to give a lot of
credibility to this obituary because she
was survived by six living children
ranging in age from 120 to
128 they hadn't even left home to go to
college
yet I thought this was a very Pro found
observation by her oldest son Golam her
oldest son said his mother had never
visited a doctor never taken any
prescription medications or over the
counter medication she only used herbs
during her life now do you think she had
access to vaccinations when she was a
child did any of her kids get vaccinated
no they're Barn up in a Little Rock Hut
up in the mountains of a village catin
Bala in corisan province in
Iran okay and I guarantee you she was
functional till very close to her death
because they don't have nursing homes
and they're not just going to find some
way to give her IVs to keep her alive
there in that rock Hut and so she had to
be still able to snap beans and skin
carrots and cook and sing lullabies to
great great great great grandkids and
whatever she did she did seed
maybe we all have this genetic capacity
to live well beyond 100 experts in
longevity experts in gerontology and
genetics tell us we all every one of us
each and every one of us in this room
has the ability to live well beyond 100
and the only reason why we don't the
shortest way to say it is because we do
too much of the bad stuff and not enough
of the good stuff that's the most
succinct way I can say it we all have
the genetic capability to do it one of
the fascinating things to me is that we
ask doctors about what to do for Health
and
Longevity now if doctors knew what they
were talking about that would make
sense but I'm a scorecard kind of guy
and so I'm looking at doctors and saying
really do they really really know what
they're talking
about when my tape Doctors Don't Lie
which came out in 1994 I had a statistic
in there from a small survey it said uh
Doctors live to be 57.6 and I rounded up
to 58 to give him the better benefit of
the doubt and doctors just went
ballistic well Wallock you got to be
lying we don't live to be 58 we live to
be 75 like everybody else well even if
they live to be 75 like everybody else
that wouldn't be too good a
recommendation because if they're the
holders of all knowledge and health and
they follow their own recommendations
they should live to be 85 or 95 or 100
or something well they didn't want to
believe me so they did their own study
and they came out 5 years later in 1999
with the answer to their study and they
found out that doctors of America lived
to be
56 so I missed it by two
years so why do we ask
people how to live a long healthful life
only live to be 56 on the average that's
because they have convinced us that
healthc care is
very very not only important but also
very um detailed it's very complicated
and you have to go to school for 14
years to know how to deal with
Healthcare and they've convinced
Americans that this is true I mean you
can't pick up a newspaper or watch TV or
listen to the radio without health care
and Medicare and Medicaid and all the
stuff being on the front right let's
look at some more scorecards and see if
we getting the bang for a buck right now
the entire world each year spends $2.7
trillion dollar for healthcare 2.7
trillion with a tea out of that $2.7
trillion dollars each year that the
world spends for healthcare the us alone
alone the US spends 1.6 trillion more
than
half and yet in April of
1990 we ranked 17th in longevity there
were 16 other countries whose peoples
live longer than we did we didn't even
rank in the top 10 you have to ask well
who's number one what did they do
different from us well the Japanese were
number one they lived to be 79.1 4.1
years longer than we did and the
interesting thing was the Japanese are
heavy smokers 68% of the Japanese smoke
three to five packs of cigarettes a day
they are heavy heavy smokers they are
the smoking Nation on Earth and yet they
have 85% less cancer and cardiovascular
disease than we do Japanese consume 12
to 15 grams of salt every day an entire
salt shaker per person we're supposed to
consume approximately one gram 1,000
milligrams a day of
salt and yet they have 85% less
cardiovascular disease than we do we
dropped two atomic bombs on the Japanese
to end World War II they've had more
radiation per person than any other
culture on Earth nobody cleaned it up
they've been wallowing and all the
radiation in the oil and water and
environment ever since we dropped the
bombs on them nobody cleaned it up and
they have 85% less cancer than we
do and so I want to know what they know
in all this adversity they're still
living longer than us and are healthier
than us you say well maybe that was a
bad study it should be redone well they
did 10 years later June of
2000 they reran the same study in the
Japanese maintain number one but they
dropped from 79.1 down to 74.5 so this
is our chance to catch up and surpass
them with all this money we're spending
but instead we Dro from 17th longevity
all the way down to 24th because we went
from 75 to
70 there's Now 23 other countries whose
peoples live longer than we do now you
don't have to be a genius to figure out
we're not getting the bang for the buck
you don't have to be a genius to say
well maybe the medications we're getting
aren't doing any good maybe the advice
we're getting is not the best no matter
what the doctors tell us we're going the
wrong direction so you can't deny these
facts okay you can't deny the facts
well there's 250,000 drugs
Pharmaceuticals in the PDR the
Physician's Desk Reference that they
have access to to treat people in
America there's new ones coming out all
the time they're always bragging about
how many billions of dollars worth of
research they spend every year to find
new drugs and if you take out the 500
antibiotics it still leaves
249,900 drugs there's not a single one
of those designed to cure anything
there's not a single drug in the pedr
except may be antibiotics might cure a
strep throat other than that that
there's not a single drug in the PDR
that cures anything they're all designed
to milk your insurance policies they're
all designed to milk Medicare and
Medicaid they're all designed to milk
your your wallet because there's no laws
requiring the pharmaceutical companies
to manufacture drugs at cure even though
they could but because there's no laws
requiring them to do it they
don't this just came out in January of
this year Health spending has biggest
surge in 11 years we're you jump right
over here say UI Reinhardt a health
Economist at Princeton said the increase
in healthcare spending is no surprise
this is what the American people ask for
when they abolished managed care what he
said there was this for about eight
years the cost of Health Care stayed the
same when there was managed care doctors
didn't like it because manage care kept
them from doing unnecessary test manag
Health Care kept them from doing
unnecessary surgeries and writing
prescriptions for Unnecessary drugs and
they didn't like it because it cut their
income in in half they weren't getting
the Kickbacks anymore and so they began
to whisper to their patients you know
there's an economist there there's a
bookkeeper making decisions what test
you should have and what drugs you
should get and what treatment you should
have it should be my job I'm a doctor it
should be my job and after a while
people said yeah it should be the
doctor's job why why is some bookkeeper
doing that and so they convinced the
American public that that Managed Care
was no good and so people then
complained to their legislators who then
voted it out and of course their
workplaces went to other things other
than Managed Care
and immediately when Managed Care got
dumped healthc care doubled and tripled
and it's just going up like a Skyrocket
because now there's no controls on the
doctors well how does this affect this
this came out in May of 2003 age 65 plus
Workforce Rose sharply since
1980 Americans are living longer and
they're threatened about their financial
insecurity what is the biggest reason
why people are worried about their
financial security Health Care Health
Care right Health Care is the biggest
thing that people worry about as you get
older you need more health care and
um there's all kinds of things happening
because of healthc care doctors always
get paid you're going to pay it your
employer going to pay it the
government's going to pay it they don't
worry they're happy right I thought this
was a really a very interesting
editorial this came out in February of
this year just last month just about a
month ago Outsourcing the American dream
how many of you heard of out sourcing
okay good that's half if Outsourcing
means that they're sending American jobs
to other countries I'll give you an
example um these big corporations are
training Indian people in New Delhi how
to speak with a Texas accent so when you
call up you know you see something on TV
you want to order or in a catalog it
says call this toll-free number or you
may want to make an appointment for a
appliance repair man to come out of your
house and put a new motor in your in
your dryer or something when you call up
they say howdy ma'am how y'all
doing cuz they've taught these guys in
Pakistan and India how to speak with a
Texas accent how can we hip
you it only rings three times and they
pick it up in New Delhi India and they
take this
order well what they said was
this by the time 2006 comes between 35
and
45% of current full-time IT jobs which
are these Information Technology jobs
will be sent overseas this amounts to 14
million jobs 14 million jobs in the next
year and a half are going overseas and
here's why while telephone operators in
the United States earn an average of
$12.50 an hour plus their health care
benefits in India they earn less than a
dollar in no health care
benefits and because of NAFTA how many
heard of NAFTA the NAFTA agreement with
all these
countries gave our government permission
to give corporations tax benefits to
send the jobs out of the country we give
tax benefits to to companies to send
jobs out of the country now how absurd
is that that is really
absurd it's absolutely criminal right it
says um payroll clerks in Asian Nation
take home less than $2 an hour and no
health benefits and their counterparts
in this country averages $157 an hour
with health
benefits so as health benefits climb and
companies don't want to pay them anymore
they start Outsourcing the jobs to
countries that don't have health
benefits and what happens to the people
who are here left in the United States
well they still have to pay for their
Healthcare this came out in June of 2003
study finds doctors skip key steps of
treatments doctors fail to take about
half the recommended steps for treating
common illnesses such as high blood
pressure and diabetes suggesting that
Healthcare in the United States isn't
nearly as good as many people thought
well that's not a
new belief
right this came out in October of 1999
doctors say they'd lie to get insurers
to pay this is a study done in eight
cities 169 internists they presented
this to the annual meeting the American
Association American Medical Association
conference annual conference in Los
Angeles in October of 1999 and I'm just
going to go over two of them this is
actually quite a thick report I'll go
over two of them and said 58% supported
lying so a severely ill 55-year-old
could get a coronary bypass even though
her pain pains not becoming more
frequent as the insurer required during
the Managed Care
days now if your pains are not becoming
more frequent and the the degree of pain
Remains the Same this is called stable
angina and how many of you heard of
nitroglycerin yeah for 30 50 cents uh
treatment you can put a Nitro tab under
your tablet May cost you six to 10 bucks
a month to deal with the pain as long as
the frequency is the same the pain level
is the same you can do that forever and
also um how many of you heard of Dean
ornish well Dean ornish was a MD PhD
from Harvard Medical School he did a
great double blind study where he took
hundreds of people with 85% 90% blockage
of their three main coronary arteries
and he put them on a restricted diet
gave him some supplements gave him low
impact exercise like yoga and swimming
and in six months time all their
arteries were open 100% without surgery
this was impossible according to
surgeons the only way to deal with
blocked arteries and the hard is to do a
bypass right there's no way you can do
that with diet and exercise and
supplements and so they made him do it
again another double blind study worked
results exactly the same well what a
doctor should say today when somebody
comes to them with angina stable and say
look let's get on a Dean arish program
it's actually going to cut your food
bill in half save a little money here
we're going to get you on a little
nutritional program uh supplement
program do some yoga you can do that for
free at home well here's a $10 tape you
can learn how to do these yoga exercises
you come back in in six months and if
you're improve we'll just keep doing the
same thing if it gets worse and we we'll
consider the surgery but there's no
doctors who do that doctors kind of lie
a little bit but they want you well
worse than that they want God to believe
that they're lying in behalf of Mabel or
Ruth or Roy says Lord you know I'm lying
but it's not because of me I'm lying
because them mean old manag uh care
insurance companies won't won't let Roy
have a triple bypass and Roy needs a
triple bypass so forgive me Lord because
I have to lie for Roy now why is that
doctor lying is he R lying for Roy's
behalf no he's lying for his own behalf
he wants
$85,000 keep that cash flow going
the other one I want to talk about
briefly is a 1997 study by the Health
Insurance Association of America found
that 75% of insurance fraud is committed
by providers which is their code word
for
doctors 75% of Health fraud health
insurance fraud is committed by doctors
who apply for payment which they get for
procedures they didn't even do they
apply for payment for procedures they
give you that you didn't
need you're the only profession or trade
in America or the world where they don't
have to go to a bank when they need
extra money they just send in a couple
of claims to the insurance company
insurance company pays
them they don't even there's not a
single doctor ever goes to jail for that
insurance companies write that off as
the cost of doing business now who pays
for that each and every one of us as
these premiums go up as more and more
doctors are doing these things and they
look at it as hey it's our money we're
going to get it anyway we we have
to this came out in September of 1997 it
was an article the Journal of the
American Medical Association young
doctors lack stethoscope skills which is
you know the primary instrument of a
doctor many new doctors steeped in
high-tech medicine can't properly use
the stethoscope what they learned was
they could just identify
20% they could just identify 20% of
heart problems that were presented to
them they could not identify 80% how can
you go to school for 14 years and not
use a stethoscope it's like a a
Apprentice Carpenter apprenticing for
seven years how can you not learn how to
use a hammer right well the reason why
doctors don't spend SP any time learning
how to use a stethoscope is because if
they were to use a stethoscope to
diagnose cardiovascular problems and by
the way ladies and gentlemen you can
identify all cardiov vastor problems
with a stethoscope it takes you an extra
10 minutes to listen to every square
millimeter of the heart and the valves
and the arteries and things but you can
do
it gain the skills to do it but then you
make an extra 30 bucks for a long office
visit but if they send you in they send
you in for an angiogram or a c scan or
an
MRI
ultrasound guess what they make $421
every time they send somebody in for
those procedures what's better 421 bucks
or 30
bucks
okay you're beginning to get a picture
develop here now this
happens this happens 3,000 times a year
in
America mild C Clark 86 years old was
was found cold stiff and blue on her
apartment
floor and um the apartment manager got
scared because he thought she was dead
so he called the paramedics and they
examin yeah she's dead and so they
called the carer he came out yeah she's
dead so they put her in a body bag and
ship her to the Albany New York Medical
Center which was associated with a
medical school there in Upstate New York
and uh so they sent an intern down to do
the final exam before they got wrote a
death certificate on her because you
can't do an autopsy on somebody until
they've had a death certificate so uh he
examines her and he probably just closed
his eye probably never seen a dead body
by himself right so oh well everybody
else says she's dead so he writes his
death certificate they take her down to
the Morgan they strip her naked take a
pressure hose blow all her makeup and
Gunk off her body put her wet naked body
into the body bag and they put her in
the freezer for 90 minutes
until the um medical examiner and the
pathologist get there to do the autopsy
90 minutes after being in the freezer
they wheel out and zip open the body bag
and Mildred C Clark 86 years old sits up
she says thank God you found me it was
cold and dark and there and I didn't
know where I
was I mean after 14 years of medical
school doctors can't even tell if you're
alive or dead that makes me
nervous and then according to Ralph
nater in January of 1993 big study
according to Ralph nater doctors kill
each year in
America 300,000 patients in hospitals
alone each year as a result of medical
negligence 300,000 are killed each year
in hospitals alone as a result of
medical negligence each year in America
one .3 million Americans are injured in
hospitals as a result of medical
negligence each year in America 2
million are infected in hospitals alone
as a result of medical negligence and
despite heroic round-the-clock nursing
care and intravenous antibiotics 990,000
to 100,000 of these 2 million each year
die in hospitals each year 2.2 million
people get what's called adverse drug
reactions of the drugs that they are
introduced to in the hospital and
despite heroic Measures 140,000 to2 200
,000 die every year you add these up
ladies and gentlemen that 3.5 million to
4 million casualties killed injured and
infected each year in hospitals by
doctors each year 3.5 million to four
million killed injured and infected each
year in hospitals by doctors it's
estimated to be double that outside of
hospitals now we're not talking about
three people a year here we're talking
about a huge number of
people
so why do we go to doctors for Health
and Longevity information in
1999 doctors were believed to be the
eighth top killer of Americans medical
mistakes are the eighth top killer of
Americans behind cardiovas disease
cancer diabetes Alzheimer disease
gastrointestinal problems liver problems
kidney problems and
doctors
today this is just out I haven't had
time to make a slide but trust me right
now doctors each year in America kill
just short of 800,000 people they're now
listed as the number one cause of death
in
Americans number two is cardiovascular
disease number three is cancer number
one our doctor kills okay now how do we
deal with this you know even even um
Thomas Jefferson said that um a little
Revolution once a while is a good thing
it's time to revolt against the American
Health Care System they they do
everything in their favor nothing in the
favor of the patients it's a miracle
it's a god-given miracle if you survive
hospital visit truly about being damaged
or infected or killed and so how do we
deal with this well we've learned
another instances how to deal with these
kind of problems when the industry is
abusing us for instance 60 years ago
when the automobile industry began to
abuse customers you know you go in for a
$6 oil chain 60 years ago and you go to
pick up your car say well it's 300 bucks
you say why that's my month's wages what
do you mean 300 bucks well you told us
to do whatever is necessary and so we
rebuilt your trans transmission we
rebuilt your carburetor we gave you all
new tires we rotated them we put in new
brake shoes new spark plugs we gapped
them we did your timing 300 bucks and
you uh kicked the counter and yelled and
screamed but in the end you paid your
300 bucks well people got tired of that
and so they started going to flea
markets and junkyards and garage sales
looking for parts for their car and
after a while the demand for these parts
and tools at garage sales and flea
markets and junkyards became so great
these sources couldn't handle the Demand
anymore so whole industry popped up how
many youever heard of NAPA Auto Parts
and Pep Boys and AutoZone and
Shooks and because now you can walk in
you can get any part you want you can
get any tool you want for working on
your own car this has turned out to be a
huge industry and that's because the
automobile industry got greedy some 60
years ago and now more more people do it
themselves and that same thing happened
in the construction industry when it got
to the point where they were charging
Little Couple 60 bucks to change the
float in the toilet and $200 to change
the light bulb and they you know little
old couples would sign a um contract for
a $6,000 roof but they didn't point out
to them that there's a rotating interest
thing or revolving interest thing and if
you didn't pay in a year it cost you
$100,000 and all these horror stories
came out so people began to go to
junkyards and garage sales and flea
markets looking for materials and tools
to maintain repair their own homes how
many you remember back in the 50s and
60s when everybody had a a table saw and
a band saw and routers and all these
tools and you turn your garage into a
shop and everybody began to do things
themselves well soon these sources
couldn't Supply Demand anymore so a
whole industry developed to supply the
demand for people who want to maintain
repair their own homes they're called
Home Depot and Lowe's and Menards and if
you don't know how to put shingles on
your own roof they'll give you a free
class okay well it's long overdue that
we Rebel on the same way against the
healthcare industry we need to do more
and more with a little bit of Education
15 minutes of reading a night listening
to tapes or CDs and your drive around
your car in any particular instance with
15 minutes of reading you can do
whatever a doctor does is that simple
for for instance a doctor has less than
$100 worth of stuff in his examining
room he's got a blood pressure cuff a
stethoscope he's got a thermometer
little rubber mallet to see if you have
reflexes well if you walk in the The
Examiner room I know you got
reflexes if they carry in I might want
to test them but if you're walking on
your own you're singing and dancing I
don't have to worry about that too much
they have a little AAA Battery pen light
you know they look in your eyes and down
your throat with and that was given to
them by some salesman for a
pharmaceutical company you can jerk it
out of their pocket look at it and
you'll see oh look at that
fizer okay so they have less than 100
bucks worth of stuff you can go to a
pharmacy or a grocery store and buy all
that stuff yourself without a
prescription with the exception of
ultrasound and radiation and uh C scans
and MRIs you can get just about any test
that a doctor would send you to a lab or
hospital for for
instance you can go and you can buy a
little bottle of test strips to find out
what your um blood sugar and blood
cholesterol is you can get little test
strips to find out if you have blood or
sugar in your urine you can get test
strips to find if you have blood in your
bowel movement to do a screen for colon
cancer and ulcer of colitis maybe
gastric ulcers uh you can find out if
you're pregnant or not for 1995 you get
a little test trip you pee on it and you
find out if you're pregnant or 30
seconds honey I'm pregnant kind of thing
right 30 seconds 1995 you don't have to
go get a physical exam get a blood test
they charge 150 bucks and then you got
to come back in three days for another
150 Buck visit so it winds up being like
$500 to find out if you're pregnant or
not you can do it for
1995 the one that I really find
disgusting are the fertility clinics you
have to pay 25,000 bucks up front before
they even talk to you because they might
slip and give you a little information
so before the doctor will see you you
got to pay your 25,000 bucks and then
they'll start talking to you about what
they can do to help you in a situation
of infertility well they want you to
believe that they are the holders of all
knowledge in this well back when I was a
kid my dad only you know uh 60 years ago
my dad only had a fourth grade education
and he knew how to artificially
inseminate cattle back then it was not a
new thing we've been doing it livestock
for 75 years maybe longer than that in
research but out in the field practicing
any farmer could do AI or artificial
insemination
themselves and uh you know with a $2.95
basting syringe and a condom to collect
SE and you can do it yourself for less
than five
bucks
so when a doctor starts telling you how
how technical this stuff is you just
sort of smile at him and say okay doc
let's move forward
here now how many you ever heard of
cholesterol raise your
hand if you didn't raise your hand I
think you're asleep
okay each year in America we spend over
a hundred billion dollars for
cholesterol testing not treatment just
cholesterol testing we spend over
hundred billion dollars a year it's a
huge industry just for cholesterol
testing that's why you know doctors made
everybody in America paranoid how many
you had anybody in your family lived in
their 80s or 90s raise your hand TR I
think most people in America have had
somebody in their family lived to be
8090 I guarantee you they ate eggs they
cooked in butter they didn't have
margarine back then they salted their
food uh these people smoked they um um
gosh they ate red meat instead of tofu
they ate eggs instead of egg beers they
didn't exercise and yet they live to be
80 90 many of them went on to live to be
100 and following their advice we're
going backwards spending hundred billion
dollar a year for cholesterol levels and
eating the way doctors have told us most
people rever their doctors we've gone
from 17th in World longevity to 24th so
it doesn't seem like all that's doing
much
good well if any of you can find me a
disease if anybody in this room can find
me any disease that is caused by
elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides will give you a million
dollars small bills in any offshore
account you want tax-free there's not a
single disease caused by elevated blood
cholesterol and triglycerides when you
have elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides I kind of look for other
things um you might have a deficiency of
nasin vitamin B3 you have deficiencies
of chromium vadium two trace minerals
you might have deficiencies of the
essential fatty acids or ratio problem
between omega-3 and Omega 6es you could
have early goiter or hypothyroidism will
cause an elevation in your blood
triglycerides and and blood cholesterol
you can have early uh diabetes you can
have early
diabetes even before your blood sugar
goes up your blood cholesterol
triglycerides go up when you have
diabetes don't take my word for it go to
the library and look at a medical book
on diagnosis what's the first Blood
changes that occur when you have
diabetes elevated blood cholester and
triglycerides what's the first Blood
changes when you have low thyroid
elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides do the elevated blood
cholester cholesterol and triglycerides
cause any disease no they're just
signals they're just signals to look
somewhere do they cause cardiovas
disease no have nothing to do with
cardiovas disease nothing well why do
doctors get so excited about lowering
your cholesterol and lowering your blood
triglycerides because they get a
kickback every time they write a
prescription for sta drugs lipor lowed
and Lipitor why would you take a drug
that doesn't really do anything doesn't
prevent diseases lowers your cholesterol
that's what they do but it causes liver
ceros and blindness that's why you got
to go in every couple of months to get
your blood taken to see how your liver
is doing they got to look in your eye to
make sure you're not going blind yet why
would you take a drug that gives you
liver curosis and makes you go blind
when it doesn't do
anything how many ever heard of free
radicals good how many you heard of
trans fatty acids yeah these are common
words today everybody in the street even
little six-year-old kids know about
these things and
um yet doctors continue to recommend to
consume free radicals and trans fatty
acids if I were to come out with a
product Dr wallik 100% pure free
radicals the finest trans fatty acids in
the world and I'd label put them in a
health food store how many people would
buy them zero I me I wouldn't sell any
of
them and yet everybody listens to the
doctors when the doctors say I want you
to use margar instead of butter margin
is nothing more than a big block of
trans fatty acids and free radicals it
is pure 100% trans fatty acids and free
radicals they've killed more Americans
with margarine in America than all the
wars put together in the 200 plus years
have been a country both domestic and
foreign and so if you have any margin at
home tonight I want you to go home and
box it up and ship it UPS to
Castro put a little note in there that
says my cardiologist says this is good
for your heart and I you know in a show
of good faith I'm sending you some
argine hopefully he'll be stupid enough
to use it I like to have my patients eat
six to 10 eggs a day the more eggs you
eat the lower your cholesterol
goes more eggs you eat the low
cholesterol goes I I personally eat six
eggs a day so I I hope you do too um
they're great
protein and if you don't fry them don't
fry them don't cook them in margarine
you want to poach them soft boil them
hard boil them soft scramble them butter
loow temperature this came out in
1995 this uh little study was presented
at the annual meeting of the American
Heart Association in Anaheim California
they said two eggs a day won't hurt and
when that report came out in 1995 that
sent a shock wave through the entire
medical system because prior to that
report coming out eggs were the father
of the devil I mean if you ate eggs you
were doomed nobody would hang around you
he's an egg eater you know
ah I really like this one makes my 10
look pretty conservative this came out
13 years ago New England Journal of
Medicine very respectable medical
journal normal cholesterol in an 88y old
man who eats 25 eggs a day now you have
to ask yourself why was this old dude
eating 25 eggs a day maybe he didn't
have any teeth and couldn't eat Stakes
anymore maybe he owned an egg Farm like
to do his own quality
control but I think it was
more more scientific than that if you
appreciate that 95% 95% of male sex sex
hormone testosterone 95% of female um
sex hormones estrogen progesterone 95%
of the weight of our adrenal hormones um
our
adrenaline comes from a master steroid
in our body is made from a master
steroid in our body called cholesterol
you can only make 10% the other 90% must
come from your
diet and when your adrenal glands are
exhausted what's the most likely thing
that you're not consuming enough of
cholesterol when you're sitting there
watching TV guys when your wife's saying
hey look at my nice night
gown would you rather watch TV or watch
me and she's got got you on an egg free
Butterfree chicken skin free red meat
free
[Music]
diet yeah have you ever wondered why
there's no flourishing colonies of
vagans all sit around and
hum how many you heard of Alzheimer's
disease that's a physician caused
disease mark my words aren't my words in
the next two years maybe even next week
it'll pop up in the newspaper there's
more than enough information to prove
that it's a physician cause disease um
Alzheimer disease is a disease that did
not occur even by another name 40 years
ago it only became recognized as a
disease 19 1979 25 years ago today it's
the number four killer of adults over
the age of 65 behind I have to throw in
doctors now doctors um cardiovas disease
cancer diabetes and Alzheimer's
disease now our
brains are made up of 75% a fatty
insulation material called myin how many
of you heard of myin good well milin is
this fatty insulation material in the
brain how you ever eaten a brain
sandwich brain and egg sandwich oh you
haveen lived until eat a brain sandwich
it is
good little bit of onion and mustard I
mean there's nothing better than a brain
sandwich it's real cheap now because
everybody's afraid of you know mad cow
disase so I buy more brains and I eat
it at any
rate this milin makes up 75% of our
brain weight it's so important to the
animal and human brain milin is 75% of a
brain weight and myin is 100%
cholesterol you can only make 10% of
your daily need the other night % must
come from your food and if you're very
very good at listening to your doctor's
instructions does that sound familiar
September 2000 Scientific American if
you listen to your doctorine you give up
eggs and eat egg beers if you give up
butter and eat margarine if you rip the
chicken skin off your chicken before you
eat it eat tofu instead of red meat the
odds are you're going to get what
Alzheimer's
disease this came out four years ago
March of 2000 Alzheimer's Title Wave is
feared it's coming they said within the
next 25 years 14 million Americans are
going to die die of Alzheimer disease
today 25 years backwards only 250,000
died of it and 25 years backwards from
that nobody died from Alzheimer disease
now why would you go from zero to
250,000 to 14 million well that's
because the baby boomers are coming
along and they listened to the doctors
they believed in technology and they
believed in doctors and they believed if
they followed the doctor's advice they
could be healthier and lived be 100 and
so now baby boomers are the ones that
get a higher rate and higher percentage
of Alzheimer disease in our old older
relatives who could care
less okay remember remember Ralph
Charles still flying airplanes at 100
Harold Stillson still hitting in golf
hole in one at
101 mumi Dusty 161 still babysitting and
singing lullabies and maybe cooking and
sewing we eliminated Alzheimer disease
and animals 65 years
ago
there's a human study that came out in
July of 1992 vitamin E can EAS memory
lost in Alzheimer's patients this was a
study by the University of California
San Diego medical school and the so
Institute Infamous for the so polio
vaccine they said that vitamin E could
bring back a certain amount of memory
and and make people functional again
well nobody could believe that was true
so they redid the study and five years
later they came out with this vitamin E
might slow Alzheimer disease high doses
of common vitamin E can slow the
devastating in clined for some
Alzheimer's patients significantly
delaying the need for nursing home care
again the University of California San
Diego university medical school now if
you can delay the need for nursing home
care for a spouse or a child or a parent
grandparent Aunt Uncle who has Alzheimer
disease by 5 years would that be
emotionally and financially beneficial
to a family of course it would why don't
doctors tell you this well because they
own the stock in the nursing home in
your town that takes care of Alexander's
patients they don't want those to get
out this came out in 2003 November 2003
a study by tus University Medical School
in Boston they found out you could
reduce your risk of Alzheimer disease by
48% by just taking uh either supplements
or fish three times a day to get the
omega-3 essential fatty acids this has
been repeated over and over and
over this just came out January
2004 people taking vitamin c and e were
78% Li less likely to have a diagnosis
of Alzheimer disease now they didn't
even think about the diet getting rid of
fried foods and margarin and sources of
free radicals they didn't even think
about eating cholesterol this was just
some antioxidants and so we know from
animal studies and and these sort of um
early studies in human beings that if
you eat enough cholesterol not fried not
cooked in margarine but poached and
softboiled and hardboiled and and soft
scrambling butter and meat medium rare
and so forth which we'll talk about in a
minute and take in antioxidants the the
odds of you getting Alzheimer's disease
is reduced almost
zero I have to go ask my doctor he's
only little to be 56 why would you ask
him now how many of you heard of high
blood pressure raise your
hand sure everybody knows about high
blood pressure very common
disease um how many of you heard of
veterinarian telling you you need to
give your dog a calcium channel blocker
a beta blocker for high blood pressure
not very often how about your goldfish
what about your parakeet and guinea pigs
you know every animal can get high blood
pressure just like people reason why
they don't is in these little pellets we
talked about earlier we put things in
there so they don't get it they can get
it but they don't get it because we put
the stuff in the pellet so they don't
get
it how of you heard that salt is bad for
you when it comes to blood pressure
Salt's going to initiate high blood
pressure how how many of you heard that
genetics has something to do with it
well both of those are wrong salt has
nothing to do with high blood pressure
and genetics has nothing to do with high
blood pressure it's a simple deficiency
of a single nutrient a single deficiency
of a single nutrient we've eliminated
high blood pressure in all these animals
what's the first thing a good farmer
puts out for his Livestock in the
pasture salt blocker Salt Lick isn't it
and there's nobody out in the pasture
telling a cow she's limited to one lick
a day is
there and I refuse to believe that my
human patients are dumber than a cow or
a sheep
say look go ahead and salt your food to
taste don't worry about it if you put
too much salt on there it won't taste
good you won't eat it remember the
Japanese they consume an entire salt
shaker per person a day 15 grams of salt
a day and they have 85% less
cardiovascular disease than we do and
Highwood pressure is not even in their
vocabulary because they don't get it
very
often well this came out in July of 1997
it redeemed my view on redeem my view on
salt says doctors lack proof that too
much salt is unhealthful after years of
telling healthy people that too much
salt is isn't good for them researchers
still don't have solid evidence to back
up that claim now what did doctors call
people who give unsubstantiated health
and medical advice for a profit call
them quacks don't they so next time they
have a doctor says look I need you to
give up salt because you're getting to
that age we got to worry about your
blood pressure say Doc you're a quack
there's no evidence to support that
claim yeah I know you want to give me
those statin drugs and blood pressure
medication even though I don't have
those problems and um you need to go
back and kind of read your stuff here
because that's not true well there was a
wonderful study done by the US
government called the sodium task force
once and for all they were trying to
prove that salt was the cause of high
blood pressure this was published in
April of
1997 and this is the bottom line of the
study it was called the sodium task
force 1997 you can look it up on the
internet the study found that people who
limited their salt intake to 1,000
milligrams or one gram a day like
doctors want you to do have six times
more heart attack 600% more heart
attacks and those who defied their
doctors and at Double that
amount if you listen to your doctor you
had six times more heart attacks than
people who defi their doctors and at
Double that
amount so what mineral are we talking
about what mineral are we talking about
when it comes to high blood pressure it
turns out it's a deficiency of calcium
now you can drink 50 gallons of milk a
day and you can't get enough calcium to
get your blood pressure down you can eat
25 pounds of cheese a day and the only
thing will happen is you'll be so
constipated you'll need a jackhammer to
have a bowel movement
if you didn't have hemorrhoids you're
going to get
them you can take all the Tums you want
you can take all the oyster shell
eggshell Limestone Coral Calcium you
want nothing's going to
happen that's because if you take a
th000 milligrams of limestone or calcium
carbonate which is Coral Calcium and
eggshell and oyster shell all those are
the same chemical formula you take a
th000 milligram capsule you're not
getting 1,000 milligrams of calcium only
140 milligram is Elemental calcium 860
milligram is carbonate and because it's
an ele Elemental form of calcium because
it's an elemental form of calcium you
only get 10% so 10% of 140 milligrams is
14 if you take two of those 1,000
milligram capsules of calcium carbonate
in any way shape or form you get 28
milligrams of
calcium it's not going to do you much
good when it comes to arthritis
osteoprosis high blood pressure paral
disease Etc Etc but we've eliminated a
lot of high blood pressure at animals
and some very famous people who didn't
want to use
drugs how many of you heard of um
menopause raise your hand say now even
the guys are raising their hand H I know
about that
one well up until about
1958 every doctor used to make 50 cents
on dispensing a little herbal formula
called Lydia Pinkham how many you heard
of Lydia pinks yeah Lady Pinks very
famous herbal formula and we get rid of
the hot flashes the night sweats but
doctors only made 50 cents when they
dispensed a bottle in 1958
pharmaceutical companies came out with
HRT Harmon replacement
therapy and all the research was done by
veterinarians and they were told not to
give it to humans because it did
Terrible Things to laboratory animals
they well that may be true in laboratory
animals but it hasn't been proven in
humans yet we're going to have to kill a
lot of women with this stuff before we
get you know too excited about taking it
off the market and so they began to
encourage women to take HRT in
1958 it turns out that HRT estrogen and
progesterone combinations premine and
and drugs like this increase the risk of
breast and uterine and ovarian cancer by
78% increase the risk of dementia and
Alzheimer disease by 200% increase the
risk of cardiovasc disease by 200% and a
new study that just came out a couple of
days ago and again I don't have a slide
for it yet and I apologize increases
your risk of asthma by 100% increases
your risk of uh gradual deafness as you
get older by 30% why would anybody want
to take
HRT well Dr Wallock you got to get rid
of the hot flashes
someway I said well why would you risk
all these terrible things just to get
rid of hot flashes night sweats see
you're just a man you have no idea I
mean women used to beat me up all the
time in my practice I say well it's not
worth it and so we went back to the old
Lydia pinkham's formulas and guess what
work like a charm there's 29 major
studies which shows it gets rid of the
hot flashes and night sweats then you
throw in the liquid calcium and guess
what 1,200 milligrams per serving you
deal with the concerns about
osteoporosis you don't have to have all
the risk from the HRT you don't have to
have all the risk from
HRT this came out actually in
2000 and they said they predicted that
the report on carcinogens or
cancer-causing chemicals which was going
to come come out in January 2002 is
going to list estrogen as a
cancer-causing chemical well guess what
that report comes out every year and
guess what's at the top of the list of
cancer-causing chemicals estrogen what
makes it most dangerous is doctors
prescribe it doctors prescribe
it
obesity 40% of
Americans are overweight now they're
obese 30 lbs overweight over their ideal
weight for their body type and height
and so forth 40% of Americans are obese
this is relatively new 50 years ago it
was like 15% and 100 years ago there was
very rarely less than 1% of Americans
were obes and it turns out it's caused
by a simple single problem I can walk on
a horse farm I can tell you in 30
seconds if the horse is on that farm are
getting all the minerals they need this
is a little working Wagon in an Amish
farm and land Lancaster County
Pennsylvania and I walked on that place
and I knew immediately that the horses
weren't getting all the minerals they
needed because the horses were eating
nibbling all along this Buckboard Rail
and then they just ate this one
particular place why did they eat that
one particular place CU that's where the
farmer put his hand when he jumped out
of the wagon every time his hot sweaty
hand full of what salt okay now my daddy
had a fourth grade education and he knew
every time he'd see our cattle chewing
on the fence and eating dirt and chewing
on the feed box instead of eating the
feed they were minerally deficient he'd
give them minerals and they'd go away
and we usually learned painfully when we
were a kid that it's not socially
acceptable to chew on the furniture and
eat
dirt bam don't do that anymore that
chair costs a lot of money
okay if you're that hungry go into the
kitchen and have a piece of pie and ice
cream or eat a Twinkie or have a RC and
a moon
pie and so people began to recognize
these Cravings which we call Pik and and
cribbing and animals and munchies and
people the munchies and people are Pik
and cribbing and animals Pik and
cribbing and animals are the munchies
and people and so we've been taught that
these cravings and the munchies are due
to a Twinkie
deficiency now if we were taught as kids
that this is caused by mineral
deficiency we'd all take minerals that
have zero calories in them Americans
would all be
slim weight problems are nothing more
than a mineral deficiency disease now
nobody knows more about weight weight
gain weight loss in veterinarians why is
that when you put an animal into the
feet lot what are they supposed to do
lose weight or gain weight gain weight
so we know the technology and snack food
companies know this they spend a lot of
money on Research learning the
technology of weight
gain and they fix their little snacks to
make sure that you just can't eat one in
fact one of them Lays potato chips even
uses that as their motto on their bag
you just can't eat
one and so they fix it so you're
minerally deficient if you eat their
stuff okay but if you take your minerals
the Cravings go away and that alone you
can lose 10 15 20 pounds just because
you're not Desiring to eat things
between meals you're not going to sit
there and watch TV and fill your face
all night because you don't have those
Cravings anymore that's not a a problem
with your self-respect it's not a
problem you don't have a deficiency of
hypnosis you don't have a deficiency of
acupuncture
you don't have a deficiency of a
fedra you have deficiencies of minerals
you take your mineral program and need a
couple of meal replacers a day I give up
some carbohydrates which you learned
from Clive McCay and and William Banting
and so forth and and Bob Atkins uh you
give up carbohydrates and your bread and
your pastas and your rice and your
potatoes and you're going to lose weight
and keep it
off it won't come back as long as you
stay on that program but as soon as you
go off your minerals the Cravings start
up again because it's a mineral
deficiency you'll always get rid of the
Cravings within 10 to 14 days now I want
to talk briefly about three serious ones
we're first going to talk about cancer
some of the more serious
diseases this came out in
1997 uh we had spent $30 billion on a
war on cancer this bill was signed uh by
Nixon when he was in office uh and
despite 26 years of spending this $30
billion do researchers suggest putting
emphasis on prevention now you give me
$330 billion one year's time I'll find
you a cure
and why couldn't they find a cure for
$30 billion I mean we only took a
hundred million to fly a man to the Moon
put them on the moon surface pick them
up and bring them
back $100 million to do that $30 billion
they look for a cure but they didn't
think outside the box they weren't
really looking for a cure they spent all
their time looking for a better
chemotherapy with your tax money because
that's where the money is well during
that time every five years or so they
double the amount of money for research
the death rate remained the same so they
weren't looking in the right place
obviously or really looking that home
hard I know your doctors didn't tell you
about this
one this one came out in October of 1998
there's a Harvard nurses health study
had 990,000 nurses 20 years of data and
they could only use 15 years of the 20
years of data in the study for these
990,000 nurses because for the first
five years there were not enough nurses
using multiple vitamins and what they
found out was these 990,000 nurses who
take multiple vitamins for at least 15
years can cut the risk of colon cancer
by 75% are there any drugs that will do
that is there a drug in the market that
will cut your risk of colon cancer by
75% no how come your doctors didn't
email you call you up call you bring you
in say look here's something really
remarkable just by taking one
multivitamin every day you can you can
reduce risk of colon cancer by 75% Yahoo
did they do that
no I bet not a single one of you got any
direct communication from your medical
doctor telling you
this they read it in their journals at
Harvard
nurses health study you believe it or
not how you ever heard that a lowfat
doubt will reduce your risk of colon
cancer and breast cancer and all kinds
of cancers how many you heard that would
you believe it or not yeah this is one
of the American Cancer Society doctors
the American Medical Association
everybody says low fat DS will reduce
your risk of cancer high fat DS increase
your risk of cancer Harvard nurses
health study 990,000 nurses 20 years of
data they compared the rate of cancer in
these 90,000 nurses comparing those that
had more than 50% of their calories as
fat which is a very very very high fat
diet compared to those that had less
than 20% of their calories as fat which
is a very lowfat diet and if fat content
of your diet had anything to do with the
rate of cancer the ones having more than
50% of their calories is fat should have
a lot more cancer than ones having less
than 20% that's real simple stuff right
well this came out in March of 1999 it
was published in the journal American
Medical Association again they compared
the the rate of cancer in these 90,000
nurses comparing those that had less
than 20% of their calories as fat versus
those that had more than 50% of their
calories in fat they found no measurable
difference the amount of fat you eat in
your diet has nothing to do with the
rate of cancer the amount of fat you eat
in your diet has nothing to do with the
rate of
cancer nothing it turns out the amount
of fat in your diet has nothing to do
with the rate of cancer it's how you
cook the fat it's how you cook the fat
not the amount of fat it's how you cook
the
fat this study came out in
1998 University of South Carolina big
study study links very well done meet to
breast cancer and and then later on to
prostate cancer and colon cancer among
women who preferred all their meat very
well done with a d a score of nine where
the fat was burnt and it tastes very
good believe me burnt fat tastes very
good I used to eat it when I was a kid
there is a 462 per greater chance of
having breast cancer than for women who
ate their meat rare or medium not a 5%
increase in Risk not a 50% not 100% not
a 200% not a 300% not a 400% but a
462 per increase in risk of getting
breast cancer colon cancer and prostate
cancer if you eat your meat cooked well
done and eat burnt animal fat now after
tonight you can't claim you were not
informed if you go home you continue to
eat burnt animal fat whether it's in hot
dog skins over the fire you know or
you're grilling chicken skin and eating
it that way or you're grilling your
hamburgers burnt you know I get people I
cringe people I want my hamburger burnt
I don't want to see any pink in there I
want it burnt burnt I want like charcoal
they're doomed even God can't help them
you know when you're that stupid God
can't help
you and when you're at the bottom in the
Jee pool he's got to let you
go now with you believe it or not how
many you heard that a high fiber do will
reduce your risk of colon cancer you
believe it or not how many you heard
that yeah that's another one of those
truisms that the American Cancer societ
your doctor wants you to believe of
course Quaker Oats likes that one right
um low fat diet high fiber diet Harvard
nurses health study 90,000 nurses they
compared the rate of colon cancer these
90,000 nurses comparing those that had
had a high fiber diet versus those a low
fiber diet they didn't like the results
so they threw in 50,000 male doctors
they compared their rate of colon cancer
the ones who had a high fiber do versus
those at low fiber now they had 140,000
human subjects and this came out in
January of 1999 it was published in the
New England Journal of Medicine very
respectable medical journal 90,000
female nurses 50,000 male doctors they
said high fiber di don't cut colon
cancer by any measurable amount zero
notada eating a high fiber diet did not
protect you in any way shape or form
from any cancer
zero why did doctors get so excited
about a high fiber DIC because it will
reduce your cholesterol that's because
it absorbs everything that you
eat including minerals that are required
to keep you from getting high blood
pressure osteoprosis
arthritis
cancer and so people who eat multigrain
breads for their toast and English
muffins and pancakes and waffles for
breakfast people who eat multigrain
pastas people who eat multi-grain Breads
and whole wheat Breads and grind their
own wheat and all that sort of stuff
for their
sandwiches and people eat whole wheat
and multigrain bread for dinner they eat
whole wheat ice cream I mean you can go
to extreme
right they have a 500% increase in risk
of all these other degenerative diseases
which Kill You So by eating a high-fiber
diet your risk of those other diseases
goes up and doesn't affect your risk of
cancer at all the only thing the doctors
get excited about really about a high
fiber it lowers your
cholesterol and does that do anything
for you no doesn't do a
thing you reduce your risk of colon
cancer by 60 to 80% fting dark berries
raspberries black raspberries
blueberries blackberries black cherries
strawberries according to the Ohio
University big study by Ohio University
reduce risk of colon cancer by 60 to
80% how many you ever heard of the trace
mineral
selenium good how many you heard the
trace mineral selenium is a great
antioxidants can reduce your risk of
cancer with you believe it or not I many
you heard that okay well this has been
kind of a recent thing they're kind of
growing crazy over selenium in fact the
information on
selenium really came out in April of
1912 in this very famous medical journal
called Popular
Mechanics April of 1912 and this fella
here professor professor Dr Von werman
from Berlin who went on about 10 years
later to get a Nobel Prize in medicine
said that he had discovered a chemical
substance that will cure cancer in mice
it turns out it's a
selenium the selenium has a selective
action against cancer cells that doesn't
hurt healthy tissues Dr waserman
believed that the cancer and mice were
so similar to those in humans that he
believed an important Advance had been
made towards the Cure that veritable
Scourge cancer in people well this was
April of 1912 we began to put the trace
selenium into animal feed pellets back
in April of 1912 to keep their rate of
cancer down this laid dormant for 84
years in human medicine nutrition until
December of 1996
when a study came out it was a
seven-year study done by Dr Larry Clark
an MD PhD from University of Arizona
School of Medicine uh he took half of a
group of 1300 people gave him 200
micrograms over seven years 200
micrograms of this Trace M selum every
day for seven years and to make a long
story short at the end of the study his
final analysis showed that he slashed
the occurrence not the risk but the
actual occurrence of prostate cancer by
69% are there any drugs that will do
that we doing a prostate exam and taking
your PSA your prostate specific antigen
blood test every year will that prevent
prostate cancer by 69%
no you reduced the actual occurrence of
coloral cancer by
64% you reduce it by 75% by taking a
multivitamin to reduce the actual
occurrence of lung cancer by 39% whether
you smoke or not about 90% 90% of lung
cancer occurs in people who never smoked
smoking is not the cause of lung cancer
it's inhaling all the fumes when you fry
food is the biggest single cause of lung
cancer all those free radicals coming
out of that margin you're frying
with how could Ruth get lung cancer she
was a good churchgoing lady never cussed
never even hung around smokers how did
she get lung cancer but she was there
early every noon after church frying
food for
everybody oh the best part of the story
is two months after this result came out
Dr Larry Clark died of prostate cancer
at age
52 now why did that happen well because
he had set this study up to show that
selenium didn't work he hated
selenium he set the study up to prove
that it wouldn't work and he wouldn't
take it and the sick part about this is
he was a professor of medicine at the
medical school of the University of
Arizona so he taught his
beliefs all the medical students there
and when he died of prostate cancer they
all said oh what a tragedy and went on
avoiding selenium they'll tell their
patients not to take
selenium this came out March 6th
2002 study says a diet rich in tomatoes
can cut the risk of prostate cancer raw
Tomatoes by 24 to 36% if you eat a
Tomatoes cooked one serving a day a
cooked tomato will reduce your risk of
prostate cancer by 52 to 60% because
there's an antioxidant in tomatoes
called lycopenes
lopin
I love this when it came out in
September of 1998 call Green Tea the Cur
all of curs why is that important why do
we have 85% more cancer than the
Japanese well our national drink is
Coca-Cola their national drink is green
tea and green tea contains an
antioxidant catechin or EG CGS that are
100 times more potent than vitamin C in
neutralizing free
radicals kin and EG G CGS and green tea
are 100 times more potent than vitamin C
in neutralizing free
radicals and perhaps a 100 times more
potent than vitamin C in reducing your
risk of
cancer
diabetes an epidemic disease in the
United States there's a million new
cases a million new cases of
diabetes every year there's 32 million
diabetics as we speak right now in
America 30 million of the 32 million
diabetics are adal onset type diabetics
that make up the bulk of the diabetic
population and adult onset type 2
diabetics make more insulin than
non-diabetics it is not an insulin
problem with them and usually if you're
asking about insulin say well I've got
insulin how can I be diabetic and so the
doctor say well you've got insulin
resistant diabetes it's not working the
reason why it's not working is you're
deficient in two trace
minerals chromium vadium and their
co-actors necessary for them to work
which are required by your insulin to
work in your body you can make tons of
insulin but if you don't have those
trace minerals your insulin is not going
to work we learned in 1957 that we could
prevent and cure addal onset type
diabetes in laboratory animals pet
animals and farm animals by giving them
these two trace minals and their
co-actors this laid dormant for 20 years
in human medicine until 1977 when they
found out that they could give
intravenous intravenous chromium vadium
and they co-actors to people who had
diabetes and they were UNC conscious
from head head injuries they're in a
coma and they were miraculously cured by
giving them intravenously these trace
minals and their co-actors now you can't
say that oh well they just believed that
they were going to get cured because
they're in a coma they didn't know what
was going
on now how come your doctor doesn't tell
you this stuff I it's been proven over
and over and over in animal been proven
over and over and over in people it's
been published in every big medical
journal America in the world it sort of
comes through every couple years as
renewed you know people look at it it's
not like it's a mystery every doctor
knows this why don't doctors tell you
this well if a doctor took the less than
two minutes that I just shared with you
this information he might get $80 for a
long visit an extended visit instead of
50 bucks for a standard visit make an
extra $30 according to the GAO of the
general Accounting Office which is the
budget Watchdog for the US Congress your
doctor makes over the 25 to 40 years a
diabetic lives after diagnosis your
doctor makes
$750,000 for every diabetic
so why would he take 30 bucks when he
can make
$750,000 and most people say well my
doctor belongs to my church I I I got to
believe any him well don't let that
protect you even members of the mafia go
to church right so I wouldn't bet on
that
one according to the US Department of
Agriculture a 100 years ago Americans
were eating a half a pound of sugar per
person per year
a half a pound of sugar per person per
year today 100 years later according to
US Department of Agriculture Americans
are eating 157 pounds of sugar per
person per year or now we're eating a
half a pound a day so in 100 years we've
gone from a half a pound of sugar per
person per year to a half a pound of
sugar per person per day that plus the
deficiency of these nutrients in our
food has resulted in this epidemic of
diabetes do you think our genetics has
changed that much I don't think
so if you look in the book rare earth
been cures one of our books
[Music]
um the guy who's doing all this uh study
on these two Trace minals back in the
1950s actually Dr Walter Merz went back
into the 1940s and began to look at
chromium levels in American blood and he
found out there was a big range in 1948
micrograms per liter of parts per
billion 28 to a th000 in 1971 it dropped
a 13 in 72 it dropped to 10 in 73 our
chromium levels in her blood dropped to
4.7 to 5.1 in 74 it dropped to 0.73 to
1.6 in 78 it dropped to 0.16 is it going
up or down it's dropping like a rock
well in 1980 it went up three times over
1978 values to 0.43 why did that happen
remember
1977 they're publishing all these papers
on how chromium vadium was good for you
and so everybody was taking chromium
vadium they run into hell food stores
and taken it and so everybody's blood
levels of chromium vadium went up but
because they couldn't cure diabetes with
chromium without all the other
co-actors in 1985 it went back down to
0.13 because people got frustrated
because it wouldn't work if you just use
those two Trace minals without the other
co-actors so between not having enough
of these nutrients the chromium vadium
and their co-actors no food anymore and
eating all this sugar more sugar less
chromium vadium we have a epidemic we
have an epidemic of anal onset type 2
diabetes
the last one we're going to talk about
is arthritis and osteoprosis arthritis
and osteoprosis
according to the Center for Disease
Control 85% of all Americans over the
age of 50 already have arthri ostosis of
one Ty or another or to one degree or
another there's not a single medical
treatment designed to prevent or fix it
aspirin Cel bio tanol ibuprofen Advil Al
Methotrexate gold shots prazone
cortisone none of those prevent cure
osteoprosis and arthritis they all have
terrible side effects many of which are
life-threatening and what makes this
really really really bad ladies and
gentlemen we learned how to prevent and
cure osteoprosis and arthritis and
animals over 300 years ago now we didn't
know all the biochemical reasons why
these approaches worked but we knew in
the last 75 years the biochemical
reasons why these little nutritional
formulas worked but we knew how to
prevent and cure osteoprosis and
arthritis and animals for over 300 years
in some societies A Thousand Years
and your doctor is still trying to just
give you
painkillers and doing
surgery how many you heard of
arthoscopic surgery of the knee for
arthritis yeah it's a very common
procedure now this came out in July 2002
arthoscopic knee surgery for arthritis
is a worthless procedure this was
published in the New England Journal of
Medicine how many of you know somebody
who's had arthroscopic surgery of the
knee yeah well if you have arthoscopic
surgery the KNE for arthritis that
doesn't deal with the systemic problem
that's going on right just one little
knee and of course doctors in 2001 and
there's only like maybe 5,000 doctors
out 1 million doctors who do this
procedure their income for that one
procedure in 2001 was 1.5 billion now do
you think they'll ever give up that
procedure no it's been proven to be
worthless published in the New England
Journal of Medicine as a worthless
procedure when their Cur is available so
they're not going to use the nutritional
approach they're not going to use a
nutritional approach they're going to
use arthoscopic surgery the need because
that's worth $1.5 billion to them and so
you have to be smart enough when your
doctor says look you've got bone to bone
arthritis of your knee in the old days
we'd have to go right to the joint
replacement surgery but right now we've
got arthoscopic surgery the knee we can
take out those little floating bits of a
bone and cartilage and then that doesn't
work anymore we'll eventually have to go
to the jint placement surgery but right
now we might be able to preserve your
knee for a year or two you have to be
strong enough to say look doc you're a
quack how many people did you kill last
month
journal the New England Journal of
Medicine the New England Journal of
Medicine July 2002 said this procedure
is worthless now we've been friends for
a long time we belong to the same church
and you're coming to me with a worthless
procedure I don't think I'm going to
visit you anymore you have to Rebel
sometime when they keep taking advantage
of you to milk your insurance policy and
milk your wallet when do you Rebel you
Rebel when you realize that your doctor
is only looking at you as a source of
income
if you follow your doctor's advice when
you have osteoprosis and arthritis
you're going to wind up like
this
Yahoo now you believe it or not whether
you believe it or not how many of you
ever heard that osis is primarily a
postmenopausal woman's problem with you
believe or not I of you heard that sure
everybody knows Oprah your doctor the
government everybody knows that
osteoprosis is primarily a posman of PA
a woman's problem well we knew a hundred
years ago that osteoprosis actually
occurred equally in both men and women
it only became a postmenopausal woman's
problem in 1958 when they came out with
HRT because can you justify treating
osteoporosis and preventing osteoprosis
with estrogen if both men and women get
it at the same rate no you couldn't you
imagine a red-blooded American man a
red-blooded eyah
hoen going to his doctor say Okay doc I
I've got that aop proess stuff I want
you to shoot me up with that
estrogen I've had estrogen today they're
not going to do it you're just not going
to do it people tend to be basically
smart right well this came out in
November of 2001 osteoprosis strikes
both sexes
equally men are as likely as women to
suffer from osteoprosis the surprise
findings well why was this a surprise
finding because all the doctors who did
that
study only graduated after the 1950 time
period and the truth they were taught
was that osteoporosis occurs primarily
in postmenopausal women results turn the
tables on the belief that women are the
prime victims the condition the findings
of the Canadian multicenter osis study a
program involving almost 10,000
participants and nine centers will
almost certainly change the way that
medical professionals deal with
unexplained bone fractures in men and
the way education about the condition is
handled now raise your hand gentlemen if
you have received a direct communication
from your medical doctor either an email
a postcard a phone call saying look come
on in I've just just learned that
osteoporosis occurs equally in both men
and women I'm so excited about this
because I can help you before something
bad happens come on in we'll do a bone
density test how many of you men have
gotten that communication from your
medical doctors look at that none as I
traveled around the world 18 countries
in the last three years a single man has
raised her hand now you well why would
that be why wouldn't doctors want to
tell their men patients uh you'd think
they'd be excited if they're altruistic
and they're out there to help you they'd
be wanting to give you this information
right well guess what would happen every
woman would immediately stop using
HRT and they're making so much money
from the Kickbacks and wrting the
prescriptions from HRT they're afraid to
rock the boat they don't want to start
anything that's going to rock the boat
so any Doctor Who today continues to
write prescriptions for women for
HRT should be put in jail for 25 years
of life without possibility of parole
and that would be the kindest of
treatments that I would figure for them
ladies when your doctor comes to you and
says I want you to take estrogen osteop
for osteoporosis you can say Doc you
take it for 25 years and then if it
works I'll take it see what he
says one of the other things you have to
do besides taking all the raw materials
to rebuild your bone and cartilage and
ligaments and tendons connected tissue
is you give up carbonated drinks
carbonated drinks are the single
greatest contributor to osteoporosis and
arthritis and fractures of the bone they
interfere with the absorption of
nutrients especially minerals digesting
protein this actually the original study
was done 10 years before this um at the
Harvard nurses health study 990,000
nurses 20 years of data and these were
all nurses over age 35 they found out
that the nurses drinking carbonated
drinks soft drinks even DED drinks
instead of water during the day had a
500% increase in risk of osteoporosis
and fractures over the water drinking
group so they went and did the study in
junior high school girls 460 junior high
school girls in nth and 10th grade they
found out that the same thing was
exactly true for them why did they only
look at and nurses and
girls because they believe it primarily
a woman's
disease but believe me it occurs in boys
too so if you have young athletes
whether they're girls or boys if you
have osteoporosis in your family or
arthritis if you have it or don't want
to get it you got to give up carbonated
drinks doctor should be telling you this
every time you walk in the door you got
to give up carbonated
drinks um I'll answer questions in just
a moment I just want to remind you
that if you don't take care of your own
destiny if you don't take hold of things
and and take control of your own destiny
life is going to take care of your
destiny for you and usually it's not
very nice and so if you take control and
rebel a little bit be one of those mean
feisty little people that defy their
doctor but you have to do it with
education you just can't you just can't
do something bad you have to know what
you're doing educate yourself and the
odds are you're going to save yourselves
an enormous amount of unnecessary misery
you're going to save eles a Gob of money
and you're going to add many many many
healthful years to your life it will
definitely help you to educate yourself
education is power education with action
is superpower don't let somebody else
even a doctor determine your future you
got to make those determinations
yourself